hi I'm Erik Bosse and alien covenant is
here along with some questions about how
exactly this story fits in the overall
timeline of the Alien franchise now I am
a huge fan of the alien movies the first
two are honestly my favorite films
unpopular opinion I know and even as the
franchise got weirder and some cases not
so great I've always had a soft spot for
the sci-fi elements in the backstory of
all of these movies so in this video I'm
going to explain the full complicated
alien timeline including the non-canon
alien vs. predator movies and why people
don't consider them canon I come on is
it just because people don't like them
like things still happen we shouldn't
just brush them off right the story is
more interesting than that and quick
heads up I'm going to talk about major
plot details from all of the alien
movies including a few minor things from
alien covenants that I don't think are
spoilers but you might think they're
spoilers so if you haven't seen it yet
and just want to go and completely blind
you have been warned okay so when Ridley
Scott announced that he was making an
alien covenant he said it wouldn't be an
exact sequel to Prometheus which
remember ended with Elizabeth Shaw and
David leaving lb 2 to 3 for the
engineers homeworld instead alien
covenant follows a separate crew in the
same universe on a ship called the
Covenant as they seek to establish a
human colony on a new world and it all
takes place that decade or so after the
events of Prometheus so it's kind of a
non sequel sequel but still a prequel to
the original aliens now I know that's
confusing so let's go back and
chronologically work our way forwards
through the whole timeline
okay so Prometheus established the
earliest events at 3.2 billion years BC
that prologue theme showed the engineers
leaving ancient earth as one of them
stayed behind drinking this black liquid
and dissolving into a waterfall and this
sacrifice was considered the origin of
all life on Earth and the promo site for
Prometheus included its own timeline for
the whale incorporation including the
birth of Peter Weyland in 1990 and of
course the company becomes this
juggernaut of technology and whalen
gives a legendary TED talk in 2023 that
outlines his vision of building better
worlds then two years after that and
2025
waylynn creates david the first
generation android that would go on as a
model for all the others afterwards
david ate the one in prometheus and
walker the one an alien covenant that
also includes later android like ash and
alien and bishop and alien okay so the
decades pass and in twenty eighty nine
that scene in Prometheus shows shaw in
holloway discovering ancient cave
paintings in scotland showing an
engineer pointing to a star map and then
four years after that and 2093 they
arrive at lv two two three on a mission
funded by Weyland and of course this
brings us to the main events of the
movie Prometheus which I don't need to
fully recap here just know that everyone
loved it and no one had a problem with
it but the key reveal here involves the
engineers so over the years they became
unhappy with the monsters they created
the human race so they plan to wipe us
out with a bio weapons this black goo
that infects us and turns us into even
uglier monsters so when David awakens
the surviving engineer that guy plans to
head to earth to begin that process but
he foiled when his ship is disabled and
he gets killed and impregnated by the
trilobite squid creature that Shaw had
cut out of her womb earlier in the movie
and this all results in this little
cutie the beacon it looks like a
xenomorph but it's not at least not yet
it's probably an early stage but more on
this later so it seems like Ridley
Scott's idea here is that the Xenomorphs
are a combination of a few ingredients
bio weaponry created by the advanced
race the engineers the engineers
themselves and Shaw whose human womb
incubated the trilobite and who
unleashed it on the engineer everything
about it that sets up some clever
cyclical irony for both the engineers
and the human race as co-creators of the
instrument of their own destruction but
this brings us to alien covenant which
takes place about ten years later around
2103 and again I'm not planning on
saying too much about this movie I don't
want to ruin it for anyone but if you
don't want to hear anything about alien
covenant you can skip to this time okay
so in 2103 the crew the covenant arrives
on this lush beautiful world but this is
also the homeworld of the engineers Shaw
and David were headed there at the end
of Prometheus and now the Covenant crew
has
on their ship and again the michael
fassbender android that we see in this
movie isn't David eight he's Walter and
without saying too much covenant does go
deeper into the history of this line of
Android and it shows how really dated
not Shaw was the actual main character
of Prometheus and the events of the
original alien film take place not too
long after this in 2122 there's actually
some fun references an alien covenant
that imply how close in time the two
movies are like the Covenant crew calls
their ships central computer mother just
like the Nostromo crew does in aliens
suggesting that they're the same
technology now it sounds like we may
still see another movie or movies taking
place in this 20-year gap between
cabinet and alien
Ridley Scott actually said that for more
alien movies are in development some of
these could also take place between
alien and aliens while Ripley is in
hypersleep or even later in the timeline
but we now know that one of these four
movies is alien awakening who said it
would go prometheus awakening then
covenant and my theory is that awakening
will tell the story of the events that
led from the deccan on lb 2 to 3 to the
full minimal form that we see and come
in okay so the rest of the main alien
timeline is pretty straightforward these
are the classic movies that started at
all really the best sci-fi movies of all
time
and yes I'm including Star Wars in that
because Star Wars is a fantasy not
science fiction yes there is a
difference the original alien is set in
2122 with the Nostromo responding to the
distress call on lv-426
they find the derelict which is the
ancient ship of the engineer which by
the way wasn't called the engineer yet
because Ridley Scott hadn't yet written
this backstory instead this guy for
years which is called the space jockey
anyway this leads to came getting
infected by a safe hugger the infamous
chestburster scenes and ripley narrowly
escaping with Jonesy and then James
Cameron's alien takes place 57 years
later in 2179
when Ripley is awakened from hypersleep
and sent back to lv-426 on a rescue
mission with colonial marines where it
quickly becomes grave
I ran until Ripley said get away from
her you [ __ ] and fights the alien queen
on if you can't tell I'm a huge super
and then alien 3 takes place right after
that with Ripley crash landing on the
prison colony fiorina 161 or fury 161
she learns if she has an alien queen
embryo gestating inside her so Whalen
can get his hands on the xenomorph
Ripley to the care she kills herself and
the baby by jumping into a fire then the
fourth movie alien resurrection codes
even crazier jumping ahead 200 years 223
79 when the United systems military uses
Ripley's blood collected from fury to
clone her Ripley's DNA has fused with
the xenomorph and now she has super
strength in acidic blood so they extract
the alien queen from Ripley and use it
to breed even more Xenomorphs and as the
morph human hybrid on the ship Auriga
which in the end crashes into the earth
supposedly killing all dziena more okay
so that's as far into the future that
the alien timeline goes but I've been
leading out a big part of the cinematic
history the two alien versus Predator
movies and when it comes to the timeline
people have stopped talking about these
because they're no longer considered
canon but why is that
so when Ridley Scott returned to the
Alien franchise basically said that when
it comes to the movies only the movies
with Ripley are considered canon and
that Prometheus in these new alien
movies would establish the Canon
xenomorph backstory leading up to the
Nostromo mission so Scott is basically
pretending that alien versus Predator
and alien versus Predator Requiem didn't
happen actually Damon Lindelof the
co-writer of Prometheus said that when
he brought up alien versus Predator to
Ridley Scott Ridley Scott give him this
dirty look but really that's Ridley
Scott's decision to make he's the guy
who directed the first alien film from
the vision of screenwriters Dan O'Bannon
and Ron Shusett and the studio that owns
this property 20th Century Fox has
basically given the reins to Scott to
decide what is and isn't part of this
timeline and I'm pretty okay with that
still what was this alternate history
from alien versus Predator so even
though it's been overwritten by
Prometheus let's still talk about it
because it's pretty interesting so the
alien versus Predator backstory was
based loosely on the late 80s comic
series alien versus
redditor and that goes more into the
history of the Predators a tribe of
hunters known as lyosha and they end up
dealing with their own xenomorph
infestation actually teaming up with
human and in the first alien versus
Predator movie writer Paul WS Anderson
used pieces of this comics backstory
along with research into Aztec mythology
and theories by Erich von Daniken's that
extraterrestrials helped ancient
cultures build pyramids
so in alien vs. predator there's a
history sequence that establishes the
earliest point of the timeline as to 996
BC it shows the Predators on earth
working with ancient human cultures they
taught them how to build and they were
worshipped as God
now the Predators returned every hundred
years using the humans to breed
Xenomorphs that the Predators would
battle in a sacred ritualistic combat
and if the Predators ever lost the
battle they would use their
self-destruct mechanism to make sure
nothing survived the idea being that
this is why so many of these ancient
cultures were lost to history so the
main events of the movie takes place in
2004 in a pyramid at Antarctica and it
ends with a chest burster popping out of
the predator creating a pretty a lien
which is a mix of both xenomorph and
predator and that per day lien becomes
the primary threat an alien versus
Predator Requiem which takes place in
rural Colorado and features some pretty
disgusting violence to pregnant women
regardless in my mind all this backstory
with the ancient human cultures is
pretty interesting and yeah there were
definitely some parallels between this
history in the new one that Ridley Scott
established in Prometheus with the
engineers replacing the Predators as the
godlike beings who guided early humans
but yeah the timeline is totally
different now like Ridley Scott extended
the earliest point of timeline from
around 3000 BC to 3 billion BC and if
you assume the engineer and the deacon
to be the genesis of any carnation of a
xenomorph which definitely seemed to be
Scott's implication that pushes a
xenomorph into the future popping up
somewhere between 2093 and 2122 instead
of running around in our present day and
again that exact xenomorph origin point
seems to be what alien awakening
we'll be about now of course if you
really stretch things there are some
ways that these movies could all coexist
like maybe the deacon wasn't the origin
of the xenomorph and elsewhere in the
universe they've been locked in this
millennia old ritualistic combat with
the Predators or also possible the
Predators could have like gone back in
time to ancient earth and brought a few
facehuggers with them I mean I don't
know
crazier [ __ ] has happened in movie
timelines before terminator dinner but
really as much as I honestly loved the
predator movies I don't want to be
forced to contextualise the alien
history in the predator universe like I
think it's best to consider the alien
vs. predator crossover movies as
separate side adventures that you're
free to enjoy or not enjoy personally
I'd rather trust Ridley Scott's visions
like bringing back that space jockey and
ending Prometheus on this striking image
of the deccan suggest that he's got a
pretty good idea of the overall world of
the story even if some of the characters
in that worlds act pretty dumb sometimes
I'm just grateful to look forward to the
future of this franchise again like sure
it might not ever be as great as alien
and aliens but the existential themes
and mythology of the engineers and the
Weyland Android and heart-pounding
suspense and horror which are still
top-notch all these things make this
series something that I will always be
fascinated by and I'll probably be a
really annoying fanboy to debate if you
ever start hating on them okay that
covers the up-to-date timeline of the
alien movies
Canon and non canon but keep an eye out
for other videos that we might be doing
on alien covenant on this channel like
I'm curious to know what you think of
the movie and what questions you have
after seen it so if you like this video
please hit like and subscribe the new
rock stars you can also contribute to us
on patreon thanks so much to all of our
current patrons especially Daniel
Hopkins you can hit me up on Twitter a
TA box with any thoughts you have about
alien covenant or any alien movie or
follow new rockstars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on our videos okay
[Music]
it's just
burster it's lemon on my chest it's cute
it's a teeny
[Music]
[Music]